a lot of what goes on today is a lot of
your listeners
are right now like beating themselves up
and scribbling notes and saying i need
to do this and i need to do that and i
need to no you don't need to do anything
all you should do is what you want to do
and if you stop trying to figure out how
to do things the way other people want
you to do them then you get to listen to
that little voice inside of your head
that wants to do things a certain way
and then you get to be you and no one in
the world is going to beat you with
being you you're never going to be as
good at being me as i am and i'm never
going to be as good at being you as you
are so certainly listen absorb but don't
try and emulate it's a fool's errand
instead each person is uniquely
qualified at something they have some
specific knowledge capability and desire
that nobody else in the world that's
just purely from the combinatorics of
human dna and development and so your
goal in life is to find out the people
who need you the most to find out the
business that needs you the most to find
the project and the art that needs you
the most because there's something out
there just for you